what were the events in traumas at
shaped Hannibal Lector into the weirdly
beloved serial killer he became the fava
beans are stewing and the Chianti is
decanting we're having lots of old
friends for dinner to explore Hannibal
Lecter's story Hannibal Lecter was born
on January twentieth 1933 in the
southeastern region of Lithuania to a
family of great wealth and Noble
bloodline his Lithuanian father count
Lecter was a direct descendant of
warlord Hannibal the Grimm while his
Italian mother's ancestors ruled Milan
for over two centuries they lived like
they had money animals education began
early and his teachers quickly
discovered his extraordinary intellect
along with a gift for learning languages
by the time he was 10 years old Hannibal
could speak Lithuanian German English
and Italian and he was on the road being
fluent in Latin in 1939 his sister
Mischa was born Hannibal was extremely
protective of her and cared for her more
than anyone it wasn't long after her
birth however that tragedy befell the
Elector family in 1941 they were forced
to flee their castle when Nazi troops
invaded a small group of Nazis led by a
brutish sadist named Lata screw toss
found electors and killed the parents in
front of Hannibal and Mischa the
children were kidnapped and held
prisoner until food ran out it was then
that GRU toss cooked Mischa in a stew in
front of Hannibal and forced him to eat
it still in shackles eight-year-old
Hannibal escaped into the woods by the
grace of wartime alliances young
Hannibal was found wandering in the
woods by Soviet soldiers the trauma he'd
survived turned him mute although he'd
fully repressed the memory of what
happened with his sister by this time
the Russians occupied Castle Lecter and
turned it into an orphanage for children
like Hannibal it's not healing to see
your childhood home but it helps you
measure whether you're broken how and
why
assuming you want to know his fellow
orphans considered Hannibal's mutinous a
sign of weakness and he was bullied
mercilessly for it
cannibal took the abuse but when he saw
other younger children being bullied he
began to lash out violently
Hannibal Lecter's particular code for
choosing his victims began here but
though he was involved in many physical
altercations he had yet to kill after
Hannibal's 13th birthday his uncle count
Robert Lecter arrived at the castle
turned orphanage to adopt his nephew
Hannibal went to live with uncle Robert
and his wife Lady Murasaki in their
country home in France Hannibal was
still mute but he and Lady Murasaki had
an instant connection using martial arts
cooking and meditation
she helped Hannibal begin to heal and he
developed a taste for the finer things
in life when he started to speak again
Hannibal added Japanese to his list of
fluent languages but tragedy would
befall young Hannibal once more when a
local butcher hurled insults at Lady
Murasaki Hannibal attacked the man later
when his uncle Robert heard about the
altercation he confronted the butcher
and in the resulting fray had a heart
attack and died in a haze of rage and
grief Lecter stalked and killed the
butcher using one of Lady Murasaki
samurai swords he cut out the man's
cheeks and ate them marking both his
first kill and his first act of
cannibalism my choice I would have used
two butcher's knife this holds him to
local law enforcement knew that Hannibal
had killed the butcher but since he
passed a lie-detector test with a
convincing story they were forced to let
him go in the wake of Robert lectors
tragic and untimely death Hannibal and
Lady Murasaki moved to Paris Hannibal's
exceptional intelligence landed him a
spot and a highly esteemed boarding
school where he focused on medicine he
completed his diploma in record time
graduating with honors as the youngest
person in the school's history at 18
Hannibal returned to the cabin in
Lithuania where his family was murdered
after he gave his sister's bones a
proper burial animal found the dog tags
belonging to the brutes who killed her
and something snapped
he went after each of the men with cold
precision removing their cheeks to eat
them Hannibal was now on police radar
and they were convinced he was a serial
killer he was
in the woods where your family died his
face had been eaten in retaliation for
the killings vlados grew tossed
kidnapped lady Murasaki and she was
nearly killed when grutas reminded
hannibal of his own parts and his
sister's cannibalism the repressed
memory pushed Hannibal from methodical
to crazed killer this monster frightened
Lady Murasaki so deeply that she fled
France and went into hiding
Hannibal never sought her out again
while Hannibal was in jail awaiting
trial for gru tosses killing he began to
do work sketching post autopsy bodies
for the medical examiner when public
outcry led to a full acquittal
Hannibal took an internship at Johns
Hopkins in Baltimore which turned into
university and postgraduate studies
although I understand why your drawings
earned you an internship Johns Hopkins
Hannibal became a highly regarded
psychiatrist with a reputation for
throwing exquisite dinner parties during
which he would often be choice morsels
of his victims to his unsuspecting
guests one of his patients the
millionaire Mason Verger was a sadist
sexual assailant who had attacked his
younger sister so badly she would never
be able to have children when he
discovered Mason's crime
Hannibal drugged him with hallucinogens
and suggested Mason cut up his own face
he did and came out of the ordeal as a
paraplegic with a lifelong grudge around
this time Hannibal began to consult with
detective will Graham on a serial killer
case which he happened to be behind when
will discovered Hannibal's true identity
they nearly killed each other in a
violent showdown in 2013 showrunner
Bryan Fuller created an arthouse version
of Hannibal Lecter's story that drew
heavily from previous books and movies
followed simultaneously created a new
narrative Fuller's Hannibal was in his
40s with a backstory that saw him go to
Florence as a young man and start his
killing there inspired by the monster of
Florence serial killer fuller drew from
the real-life set of 16 ritualized
killings that took place between 1968
and 1985 I met him
twenty years ago it most wrong
the most arrow Florence Fuller's
Hannibal was also the Baltimore PD zon
call psychiatrist for profiling purposes
he didn't just work sporadically with
the department he acted his therapist
and many of his colleagues including
will Graham with whom he had a deeply
intense and complicated relationship
this version of Hannibal wasn't just the
Chesapeake Ripper he often mimicked the
killings of those he had been tasked to
help catch adding to their body counts
is the organ harvester disguising his
work as the crimes of a serial killer or
as a serial killer this guy's in his
crimes is the work of an organ harvester
the show's three season run offered a
textbook manual and how to identify
Hannibal's gaslighting practices which
he used the frame Graham for a series of
killings he himself committed all the
while convincing Graham that he actually
was responsible Brian Fuller's Hannibal
didn't just deepen the relationship
between will and Hannibal a number of
key characters were added who helped
make this new iteration of Hannibal
Lecter profoundly three-dimensional many
of them appeared marginally in Thomas
Harris's books but fuller gave them new
life in this version lady Murasaki's
made CHEO helped Hannibal find torture
and imprison the men who killed his
sister a gender flick dr. Alana bloom
first mentioned in red dragon as Allen
became a pivotal figure torn between
helping a troubled will Graham and
actively being gaslighted by her serial
killer boyfriend Hannibal Red Dragons
relentless tabloid journalist Freddie
Lounds was also gender flipped new
characters included FBI agent Mirim lass
who discovered Hannibal's identity but
disappeared before she could tell anyone
lass was presumed dead when her severed
arm was identified but it was later
discovered that Hannibal had kept her
alive for years in an underground bunker
and Fuller's Hannibal introduced the
killer's own therapist
Bedelia du Maurier who provided
incredible insights into Hannibal's mind
as well as a sense of fear about who or
what she suspected him to be what
Hannibal does is not coercion
it is persuasion hannibal lecter was
convicted of multiple homicides and
remanded to baltimore state hospital for
the criminally insane
hospital staff soon learned hannibal was
unlike any of the other psychopaths
housed in their facility he was a master
of self-control able to manipulate his
body and vital functions with such
precision as to pool machines he
actively cultivated his so-called memory
palace detailed rooms in his mind filled
with art books and places he hoped to
see again in person my palace is bust
even by medieval standards one day
Hannibal faked the seizure and proceeded
to kill a nurse just because he could
the incident forced hospital
administrator Frederick Chilton to
create entirely new protocols on how to
handle Hannibal which included
absolutely no physical contact
Hannibal's only Ally was Barney a
compassionate orderly who became as
friendly with him as anyone could while
Hannibal might have been one of the most
disturbing serial killers ever caught he
was also still one of the psychiatric
community's greatest minds especially
when it came to people like himself in
1978 will Graham came out of retirement
to help Baltimore PD with a series of
brutal family murders that were taking
place on a lunar cycle
he won't stop why not because it makes
him God would you give that up will
approached aníbal once more for help and
together they identified the tooth fairy
killer as Francis Dolarhyde a film tech
who was choosing targets through their
home videos the case ended with dollar
hides death but Hannibal continued to
write will letters claiming that will
was the only person in the world who
truly knew him
Hannibal Lecter would have no contact
with anyone other than Frederick Chilton
Barney and orderlies for the next five
years that's when the FBI sent in
Special Agent Clarice Starling to get
Hannibal to talk about a former patient
who was suspected of being a serial
killer known as Buffalo Bill Anibal saw
right through Clarice but he also found
himself drawn to her and now this ham
handed segue into a questionnaire in a
cruel game of quid pro quo he got her to
reveal personal details about her life
in exchange for information about
Buffalo Bill although only some of what
Hannibal told her turned out to be true
while Clarice earned her FBI badge
Hannibal staged an elaborate escape that
involved wearing the face of a police
officer monitoring him he wound up in
the Bahamas where Frederick Chilton
happened to be vacationing Hannibal
called Clarice to tell her he wouldn't
be seeking her out and said I have no
plans to call on you Perry's the world's
more interesting with you in it he then
implied he'd be seen Chilton soon and
said I'm having an old friend for dinner
Chilton was never seen or heard from
again following his escape Hannibal
Lecter went through extensive plastic
surgery on his face sparing only his
nose for fear he'd lose his extra
sensitive sense of smell he started
going by doctor fell and set up shop in
Florence where he rebranded himself as
an art expert and museum curator now
letting me know cache to the library for
stipend Hannibal was of Italian heritage
on his mother's side so he began to
investigate his bloodline alongside his
curate all duties but despite his
efforts he wasn't as incognito as he
thought mason verger had been stewing in
his rage for years and he'd put a
multi-million dollar price tag on
Hannibal's whereabouts he planned to
enact his revenge by feeding his old
nemesis alive two wild boars in the
meantime a disgraced Clarice Starling
who had been demoted following a botched
heist figured out what Mason Verger had
planned and attempted to find Lecter
first in an effort to save her career
Hannibal kidnapped Clarice and Mason's
younger sister killed her brother a
crime that Hannibal took the fall for
animal slowly came to accept how the
horrific trauma of being forced to eat
his own sister had shaped his subsequent
crimes and desires while he was
attracted to Clarice he also saw his
sister in her would you stay with me in
my presence Allen hold my hand Clarice
could have some fun
her antidotes from their quid pro quo
games all those years ago created a soft
spot in Hannibal leaving him oddly
protective of her and humans fighters
yes even so this didn't stop Hannibal
from hurting Clarice he attempted to
brainwash her into believing she really
was Mischa in order to have a proxy of
his sister back
but Clarice was too strong mentally and
she overpowered Hannibal's attempts
during that process of hypnosis though
Clarice was altered mentally and she
became a different kind of student of
Hannibal singular psychopathy the two
became romantically involved and were
last spotted in Buenos Aires it remains
unclear whether Clarice was with him
because of his hold over her or if she
actually chosen to align herself with
the serial killer she'd once hunted
would you ever say to me stop if you
left me in town check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]